si vous aviez une fille
est-ce que vous vous accepteriez je ne
dis pas vous souhaiteriez quel est de
l'amour l'expérience quand vos jeunes
filles dans vos livres j'ai vu une fille
je suis à 20 ans un homme galère de
l'épouser de passer sa vie avec
mais si
ça coûte de chance que j'arrive une fois
tous les tous les 1000 ans alors si ça
se passe pas pour elle comme ça je lui
souhaite de vivre d'essayer de faire
différentes expériences oui comment vous
expliqueriez vos livres à votre fille
je lui dirai je crois que ça se passe
comme ça que les gens s'aiment et
puissent se laissent et puis c'est de
s'aimer à nouveau etc et puis la
principale chose que les gens craignent
c'est la solitude et que c'est ce qui
explique beaucoup beaucoup d'aventures
qui n'ont pas d'autres
significations on trouve généralement
que vous avez l'air triste est-ce que
c'est votre avis